[Music]
i repel that is Felicity Jones etching
her name into Star Wars lore now
Felicity and rogue one is packing
theaters right now and this Friday she
starts in another movie that is part
fantasy part drama a monster calls
Felicity plays the mom to 14 year old
Scottish born actor Lois mcdougal how
does the story begin was the boy too old
the kid as he deals with his mom's
terminal illness lewis is confronted by
a monster in the form of a tree voiced
by Liam Neeson what do you think made
Lois so perfect for this he's real
absolutely real where did that come from
in you have you had it's an experience
like that yeah I was as similar me my
mom my own mother passed three years ago
so that definitely all those two
experiences were completely different it
gave me it did give me ask you know a
bit of an understanding of always going
through Liam as Neeson's movements were
recorded in motion captures so they can
be animated later and the reason we're
doing the motion capture is because I
captures his movements and not just as
voice acting so I think you did a
fantastic job
it's almost time for the holiday so do
you guys have any traditions I very very
traditionally yeah my two boys myself a
couple of buddies are coming up light
the fires cook the turkey do you I guess
I don't want to say I do